so you've mentioned fasting would appear
to be the the Perrine or the 8020 of
what we're looking at here for the vast
majority of people it's free
I mean site is actually better than free
like it's it's cheaper than what you're
doing at the moment what else would you
as a disclaimer we are not your doctor
this is not medical advice please seek a
physician etc etc disclaimer disclaimer
what else do you think is an optimal
strategy that some people if they chose
to would be able to undertake sure well
what I do is I
besides intermittent fasting I also
exercise exercises the other thing that
raises nad and lose these longevity
pathways and we've also known for
centuries that this is healthy right so
we're not discovering anything that new
other than what types of exercise seem
to activate these longevity pathways the
best and what seems to work best is the
high intensity interval training is to
get the body stressed so just as
intermittent fasting tricks the body
into thinking your food running out
exercises tricking the body into
thinking I might have deriving a
marathon or yeah that exactly there's a
saber-toothed tiger in town okay so that
that's exactly right so the the high
intensity seems to really stimulate the
body's defense networks even more than
just a long walk or or a steady long run
it's all about varying it right the high
the low so intermittent fasting it's its
food no food and intensity training is
running stop running stop hypoxia oxygen
hypoxia and it's that up and down that
seems to work really well that's why
whatever you're doing do something
different and get your body into shock
so the thing to think about is the
concept is called hormesis but really
the concept of hormesis is just whatever
doesn't kill you makes you stronger and
longer live by the way so keep your body
on edge it sounds like all of the things
that are good for you are really
uncomfortable
or a lot of the things that yeah well
that's the say I think people say oh why
is cake taste so why does it taste so
good
why doesn't Sydney on the couch feel
good no other way around why doesn't
exercise feel good and why is sitting on
the couch bad for you I mean that's
exactly the reason is that you've got to
put your body in the this slight painful
experience to get it to react otherwise
it becomes complacent and your body just
falls apart
[Music]
you